[Music]
every night Worldport processes nearly
half-a-million smalls they've got to
work fast or risk a cardboard logjam
conveyer belts take the small straight
up to the cores fourth floors workers
deep bag them and drop them down a chute
where they'll soon be individually
divided and sorted check this table is
basically just getting everything off
the belt still the belts don't overload
and we have
[Music]
the smalls now catch a ride on a
different conveyor belt ferrying them to
a station called the induct area at the
induct area world 14 members quickly
place the items label up on a moving
track over 2 miles long
this unique snake-like conveyors called
a tilt trace order it boasts over 6700
packaged holding slots each specially
designed to hold one item at a time but
a face down package may as well have no
label at all
[Music]
the tilt Trey's ingenious design is all
about routing items automatically as
fast as possible to their proper
destinations here's how the tilt tray
operates by a computer hooked up to a
camera as each package hits the tilt
tray they pass through this specially
designed camera tunnel inside
state-of-the-art laser light readers
scan the smart label in nanoseconds and
identify the packages zip code the
camera instantly sends the information
to servers in the world ports conveyor
belt control system telling the
conveyors exactly how to maneuver each
package into the correct receptacle
separated by destination zip code
whether it's going to 902 100 or the
Pentagon each tray gets a signal when
it's assigned zip code is approaching it
dumps the parcel into a power bag the
pace is fast and furious
big time around here can get pretty
crazy the hardest part about this job is
their specific destination second yes
a little harder than other
and if you happen to work in that area
then you're gonna have a very busy day
but even the most cutting-edge
technology needs a back-up plan if the
camera tunnels can't lead the labels the
package can go AWOL to solve the problem
UPS designed an intervention process
called teller coder if a smart label is
damaged or the package label is
handwritten or has a bad barcode cameras
register the problem and send an image
of the label to the Teleco ting
Department here a damage control
technician looks at the label on a
computer then manually assigns a zip
code to the package from then on the
system will recognize the item as a
smart package basically what Teleco does
is it takes a nun smart or unreadable
package and makes it smart and readable
so once again the technology can do what
it does and get that package to where it
needs to go in the most efficient manner